hey hello everybody and welcome to
Episode number 16 of my payto pay
flipping series we're going to go from 0
to 100 Mil using the grand exchange only
today we're starting about 16.3 mil or
so uh you might notice that's a little
bit different than where we left off at
uh the reason for that is because we
actually um recorded these clips a
couple weeks ago and a couple weeks ago
I was insanely busy didn't really have
enough time to actually play the game
make any flips uh what kind of ended up
happen is we ended up breaking even so
it kind of just reset so we're just
starting again
um we basically just have a bond run day
13 or something and we're starting at
about 160 mil so we're going to see
where we can go from here and yeah let's
get started so what we're going to start
by doing is actually some Dragon darts
um the last two weeks this is actually
one of the only items that was kind of
successful um has about 40 GP margin on
it so we're going to go ahead and buy
good um amount probably 10,000 uh which
I think is the buying limit so yeah
we'll see how that goes and uh next up
we're going to do some mythal ore has a
7 GP margin on it uh which n all right
anyway for the item and we'll buy
probably a full buy limits worth uh so
about 10,000 to 13,000 somewhere around
that okay so we have successfully uh
flipped the entire amount and we did
pretty decent especially on the mythal
or or sorry on the dragon darts um so to
start off the dragon darts we got a 39
GP margin and 10,000 of those gives us
almost 400k so that's a pretty nice flip
actually mind you it did take about 10
mil to do um the meth ore we got 13,000
of them for a 7 GP margin gives us about
91k that's about 500k in total so not
too bad and yeah let's get some new
items and buy new I of course mean the
same item which we're going to do again
because it worked fairly well so we'll
probably do another 10,000 or so still
has about a 30 40 GP margin on it so
that should be an easy 300 400k or so so
actually looks like the gold bar has a 6
GP margin on it and for the price and
how many are sold that's pretty decent
um and I'm pretty sure the limit is
10,000 so we'll go ahead and to uh
roughly around 10,000 actually we'll
bump it up a little bit and see what the
limit is
anyway okay we are back and we've
successfully flipped um about 6,000 gold
bars and 10,000 Dragon darts so the
dragon darts gave us a pretty nice
profit again of 30 GP margin on each one
giving us 300K the gold bars um we only
got about 6K of them but we did get
actually 15 GP margin which pretty good
G us about 100K on the gold bars so 400k
in total uh so not too bad um but let's
see we can do even
better so there's actually about a 1K
margin on the dragon citar so we'll
probably do a Bine worth limit of that
uh which is 70 if you didn't know um so
it'll be kind of an easy 70k but still
not too
bad and the palm tree seed's actually
been pretty decent in the past and it
has about a 1200 GP margin on it right
now so we can do um 200 of them and that
would give us a pretty nice profit
actually so we'll come back when we've
sold these things
okay so the dragon simitar like I said
got us about 1K on each one and 70 of
those given us about 70k very quick flip
uh but not a whole lot of money so
whatever uh the palm tree seeds worked
pretty decently again actually we got
about a 1,300 GP margin on them and 200
seeds hitting the limit would give us
250k so i' definitely give these a try
um if you have a spare 10 mil lying
around uh but yeah let's continue on so
we've just checked the dragon plate legs
and actually has a 3 K Le margin on it
which is um pretty decent uh for the
price anyway uh 3K on each one we can
probably afford um the buy and limits
worth which is 70 I believe or maybe
it's 80 I don't know somewhere around
there uh but anyway we'll do let's see
how much can we actually afford
here and we'll do 70 roughly
anyway okay we are back and um we're
actually making less profit still some
but we see if we can turn this around a
bit um so the mythra ore actually went
really well we got 13,000 of those again
and 14 each giving us about
182k uh the dragon plate legs we in the
end of the day after all that crap we
went through uh to sell them we only got
about 50k from that so not really worth
it kind of a pain in the butt actually
um but yeah let's continue on so these
super energies actually have about a 90
GP margin of them which is pretty decent
um they've kind of gotten a little worse
recently I'm not really sure why
why um but yeah we'll do them again um
now that they have a little bit of a
better margin so we'll do
2,000 and last St I think we're going to
flip some Dragon axes um it's about a
90k item and actually has a 2K margin in
it uh which is pretty good so we're
going to go ahead and do that we'll see
if we can actually for 70 which is a
limit I think we can let's see here
we'll put them in for 91 402 and 70 will
bring us
to actually that's yeah no yeah we have
enough
perfect so the flip are in and
unfortunately we actually suffered a
200k loss on the myth or fortunately it
dropped 13 GP losing this about 170k uh
we did make it up on the other two items
the super energy we got a 100 GP on each
one and 2,000 of those given us about
200k uh the dragon axes we only managed
to get 20 of but we did get a pretty
good margin of actually 4500 it's about
91k there so probably only made like
100k off this flip
unfortunately um but we'll see if we can
do a little better next time okay so
next up we're going to do the hood of
darkness and now you notice I actually
put five quantity in I I looked at the
RS bu graph and it did not look like it
the price was this low so I was just
going to try to guess what the price was
and I instantly bought five of them uh
by accident kind of um so we're going to
kind of just use this as a expensive way
to actually check the margin at this
point um so yeah we bought five of them
for 66k unfortunately that wasn't a very
good idea uh we're going to sell one of
them for like I don't know maybe maybe
less than that maybe like 50k
um just oh we got five quantity and we
got to lower that down um but yeah we're
going to sell one of them just to see
what the margin actually is and then
we're probably going to try buying some
more of these to kind of cut our losses
a little bit um but yeah let's see what
the margin is actually that's a pretty
big margin 40K on the hood of Darkness
we'll definitely try buying some of
these so more anyway but first we'll put
these in here for about 166k and then
we'll go buy um I don't know we'll see
how many we can afford after this okay
so we'll put the offer in for 20 of them
at 122k each so you can see here the
room Dart actually has a massive margin
on it I'm not sure how many people
actually use the Rune Dart um but with
150 GP on each Dart and it's only like a
sevener GP item like we might as well
try this um so an offer in for probably
a couple thousand of these at least
maybe we'll just do the buying limits
screw it we'll just do 10,000 and yeah
hopefully we can at least get some of
these and last up we're going to do some
gold ore um had a pretty okay pretty
okay margin um nothing too special but
we had some money left over so we want
to at least use it for something uh so
we'll do 13,000 of these and come back
when our items have
sold okay so we are back and U we
actually sold the hood of darknesses for
a 44k profit like it was before which is
pretty awesome we managed to get 10 of
them and then I think we actually hit a
buy limit for them uh cuz I actually
bought relatively quickly um so we got
440k from the hoods of Darkness uh the
gold ore we just totally broke even on I
believe and the Rune darts we have not
sold yet we've just bought them so far
um but I'm pretty impressed with this
hood of Darkness so I think we're going
actually try some more items in the
armor set and maybe just a hood of
Darkness again as well okay so we're
going to be manually checking the margin
here so we bought the gloves of Darkness
for about
250k and yeah pretty good margin on that
as well 43k on the gloves of Darkness um
so we'll definitely go do that as well
I'm pretty sure the limit for these
items are 10 on each one um so we spend
the money to check the margin then we
get pretty much nine flips um so we'll
go ahead buy 10 of these and um yeah
we'll probably try some other armors
actually for this as
well okay let's do the boots oh my God
is it confirm oh okay we're good we're
good uh we bought the Jesus H bought the
boots for 270k and we're selling them
for
29k even better that's like a 60 GP
margin 60 GP 60k um it's pretty sweet
actually uh so we'll go ahead and buy 10
of these as well um hoping to get a
solid amount of money from that actually
and last up we're going to do a dragon
axe flip as well still has about a one
or 2K margin it which is pretty good and
I we'll do 70 and yeah that's about it
um oh wow we already got a glove sweet
um yeah we'll come back when we've sold
some of the
stuff okay so we are back and we were
quite successful on this flip um to
start off the dragon axe we got 2500 in
each one uh only got or sorry we got 70
axes in total so that's 175k from that
pretty decent the Rune darts we broke
even on so nothing there um but the
boots of Darkness got a almost a 60k
margin on each one and and 10 of those
gives us about 600k mind you we did
check the margin so a little more
realistically like 530k but still pretty
sweet uh the gloves of Darkness we got
40K on each one and seven of those give
us about 287k so we actually broke one
mill on this flip so we're definitely
going to try these uh Darkness sets
again so we're actually just checking
the margin for the boots of Darkness
here uh so we bought him for
248k and we're going to sell them for
213k so that's still like a 45k margin
that's still pretty nice um I think we
might try to buy 20 this time uh cuz
we're actually going to leave it in
overnight so we can hopefully get a
little bit more than 10 this time next
up we're going to do the hood of
Darkness again um so we're just buying
it for
250k and we're selling it for 157k oh my
God that has a almost 100K margin on it
jeez so we did just lose 100K but
assuming we buy buy 10 of these that's
going to be quite worth it uh especially
since we're leaving it in overnight uh
we kind of just want to have the right
price and next we're going to do the
gloves of Darkness as well might as well
try them all um so we bought it for
something like 260k and okay that's not
huge margin on that one it's still
actually pretty decent compared to some
items but I'm not sure we're going to do
that or not um yeah maybe we will yeah
why not we'll put an offer in for 20 of
those still a pretty decent margin
relatively
other
items okay so we actually checked this
book of Darkness set as well um has a
way only 22k margin it but uh we're
getting tired so we're going to bed
we'll buy eight of these and see if we
actually manag to buy any of this stuff
uh so we'll check back uh when some of
this is
sold okay we are back and we did quite
well on all these items actually uh the
most notable being the gloves of
Darkness um but let's start with the
lower ones first uh so the boots
Darkness uh we got five but we're only
going to count four cuz we did check the
margin we're going to do that with the
rest of these cuz it is a solid amount
of money to check it so it should be
counted in the final tally uh so the
boots of Darkness we got four um and 35k
on each of those gives us about 140k uh
the hood of Darkness we got about eight
of those and 25k on each gives us about
200k in
total um the books of Darkness we did
kind of okay on 27k
and um well realistically only three
books so we only got kind of like 70 80k
on that but the gloves of Darkness we
did insanely good on we got all 20 and
we did sell them in two kind of
different clumps uh but in total we got
about over 1 mil we got
133k so that is really good especially
for how cheap the item was realistically
to get that type of margin probably got
in total about 70k on that item in total
we got, 1500 1.5 mil from this flip uh
which is pretty sweet and I think that's
where we're going to end the episode so
in the end we ended the day at about
20.5 mil and we started at about 16.3
mil so that is about 4.2 mil we made
this episode which is probably one of
the highest if not the
highest and uh yeah Darkness set really
awesome I will be trying to come up with
these a little bit more frequently since
I'm kind of excited about having a good
item to flip I think we're going to
start getting into some higher items now
that we got a bit of a cash ATT going so
if you want to see more uh items like
this higher value items that have higher
rewards uh leave a like or comment uh
what items you would suggest uh cuz I
actually got this from a user
suggestion um a couple weeks ago so yeah
I hope you guys enjoyed and I'll see you
guys in episode 17
[Music]